Je vais devoir être honnête avec toi avec
toi là-bas qui m'a fait flipper
d'endormir tout le monde comme ça dois-
je m'inquiéter oh bon
allez pas de tuvalu Graziano hey coach je
ne sais pas mais je dois aller mieux  vous pouvez
fermer l'ensemble les joggeurs dans le moniteur
ont entraîné oh non cliquez sur la porte qu'est-ce
que c'est ouais je suppose que je suis Kareem je vais
conduire
hé hé non non non c'est une voiture de police
tu ne peux pas non ce n'est pas possible
dame c'est une voiture de police d'
accord d'accord
chansu Ariane OCD Kokua
an e le le monsieur
monsieur excusez-moi monsieur j'ai besoin de parler à
quelqu'un
Père Noël comme un regard de police Je suis un
citoyen allemand et j'exige de voir l'avocat
Maju demander si nous ne le faisons pas '  Je ne vois pas la logique
vouloir récupérer à la fois bon film
tu conduis toujours comme ça Je n'ai jamais
conduit avant
super
hé c'est une façon pour nous d'être en retard
[Applaudissements]
toi